and according to Washington Post
reporter Jennifer Rubin
that's going to come back to bite
Republicans in the 2024 election
Jennifer Rubin with the Washington Post
had a great new article this week the
title is right-wing judges May
the GOP
and she spends about a page and a half
talking of course about last week's
ruling with regard to the Texas judge
who banned the abortion pill
used a bunch of activist language in the
ruling you know completely violated the
I think it's a six-year statute of
limitations to even challenge the FDA on
a drug being on the market because
mephess perone uh uh I forgot how to say
it I'm so sorry
um
Memphis Stone yeah mepheprostone has
been on the market for 20 years so the
judge way missed the statute of
limitations but still decided nope I'm
gonna ban it anyway
and the Public's pissed and that's what
Jennifer Rubin is talking about so let
me read this from Reuben's article again
I think it's very well written and I
think it's very on point here it is
it is one thing to Gin up the base on
the uninvented threats from critical
race Theory or the great replacement
Theory but when the Maga movement's
judges begin to inflict radically
unpopular edicts on those outside the
right-wing audience that risks sparking
a counter response a determined
broad-based movement insistent that the
United States not turn the clock back on
Decades of social progress Republican
setbacks such as the disappointing 2022
midterms a progressive Democrat last
week winning a crucial Wisconsin Supreme
Court seat and Rising support for
abortion rights over the past year
suggests that conservatives may have won
the battle to stack the courts with
ideologues but might be losing the war
for public opinion and ultimately
electoral control the more the Supreme
Court diverges from overwhelming public
sentiment on issues such as abortion
guns and voting rights the more strength
and more allies the Progressive Movement
May gain
I kind of like the sound of that now
it's obviously not worth losing our
rights in the meantime because God only
knows if we're ever going to get him
back but Reuben's overall Theory
is that it's one thing for these
horrible Republican politicians like
what we have down here in Florida you
know to push the CRT bans to push the
transgender bans to go after woke Disney
and you know the same things happening
in Texas with the bands in Oklahoma and
all the red States it's one thing to do
it at the state level because you're
doing it to an audience that typically
likes these things because as I
previously said they don't understand
them
but when the judges come in
those decisions aren't local
those decisions are national
meaning they don't just affect the red
States they're affecting the blue States
but more importantly they're affecting
those swing States
kind of like the overturning of Road Did
Last Summer that played a massive role
in what happened in the 2022 midterm
elections
we even saw red States like uh uh Kansas
veto on their ballot in 2022
a ban on abortion
so even in red States these things
aren't that popular
and if these judges continue down this
path as Reuben says you're handing 2024
to the Democrat well to the progressive
she says it's even better
hand it to us we'll take it we'll fix
the problems we have ideas
we have better ideas than Republicans
have because r d ideas don't involve tax
cut tax cut tax cut
but in the meantime people suffer and
that's not okay
that's not okay at all
these activist judges are doing the job
that Republicans put them there to do
and the voters need to remember that
when they head to the polls next year
yes the judges might be the ones doing
it
but you have to punish at the ballot
the ones who put those judges there in
the first place otherwise you're going
to end up with more Republican activist
judges giving even worse rulings than
what we've already seen
I am Farren cousins sitting in for David
packman don't forget you can find me at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fair and balanced and all across social
media at farrenbalanced we'll be right
back with more on the David packman show